hey there friends today we're going to
learn about nuclear power
and to do so we're going to visit my
home state
idaho that's right land of the potatoes
and also
nuclear power if you've driven through
idaho there's a good chance that you
passed by a quaint small town called
arko
where you'll find the restaurant pickles
place home to the atomic burger
wait a radioactive burger sounds a
little
disturbing actually arko became the
first city in the world
to be powered by nuclear energy and of
course
arko became the first city to serve
atomic burgers
grilled and seared to perfection using
nuclear energy
but what's going on under that grill are
they using glowing green rocks to make
those delicious atomic burgers
let's find out
nuclear power plants often look ominous
and a little bit scary
but they produce power the same way most
other power plants do
simply put they boil water to create
steam
which spins turbines to produce energy
most nuclear power plants use light
water reactors
to generate electricity which are made
up of five basic parts
first off we have the core of the
reactor where fuel rods are inserted
next up we have the containment shell
that encases the reactor
and the spent fuel rods within there we
have a supply of water which is boiled
to reduce steam
that steam then rotates a turbine
attached to a generator
which produces electricity this act of
turning
an electric generator is actually the
same process that's used for
coal gas geothermal hydropower and wind
power
no matter how complex the electricity
generation system
that all boils down to the same idea
basically
turning a wheel one of the oldest
agricultural era human
inventions and that's what makes
electricity
finally we have excess steam or water
vapor
which is the only direct emission from
nuclear power generation
easy as pie right well it's actually
pretty complex
so how is the water heated exactly
nuclear energy isn't as easy as lighting
up a grill and it requires us
to go down to the smallest unit of
matter the atom
here we get our energy at the atomic
level but it's not from the atom alone
no to gain energy we need to split the
atom
this process is called fission which
occurs when neutrons are fired
an atom causing it to split into
separate atoms of other
smaller elements this split produces a
huge amount of energy which is largely
converted to heat
which boils the water and produces steam
however we need a special kind of atom
for fission to happen
and most nuclear reactors use
uranium-235
wait why uranium-235 though well first
uranium-235 is big not a triple quarter
pounder big
but big on the atomic scale in the
atomic world this is known as being
heavy
secondly uranium-235 is unstable because
it's not only
big but it's also an isotope meaning it
has a different number of neutrons
than the more common form of uranium
which is uranium-238 which has
three more neutrons this makes
uranium-235
unstable or fizzle like fission
which means it can be split by a neutron
thereby producing other elements
energy and more neutrons those produced
neutrons crash into other u-235 atoms
splitting them and causing a chain
reaction which is what makes nuclear
energy work
this chain reaction is really important
to note because it's what makes a
nuclear power plant so different from
its
well more destructive cousin the atomic
bomb
in atomic bombs the same process of
nuclear fission is used
except that it's a fast destructive
runaway and uncontrolled reaction that
results in massively powerful explosions
not something that we would want to
happen in a nuclear power plant
now a little goes a long way when it
comes to nuclear fission
the fuel is actually composed of tiny
pellets of uranium-235
each the size of a pencil eraser but
each also has the equivalent energy of
a ton of coal yes a literal ton
these pellets are packed together to
form fuel rods which are bunched into
fuel assemblies
and then placed in the nuclear reactor
nuclear fission is therefore
really powerful and can generate a lot
of heat from very little material
but to keep temperatures from getting
too hot which would cause a nuclear
meltdown and
no i'm not talking about melty cheese
unfortunately
the reactor is therefore cooled with
water
when more heat is generated by the
nuclear reactor than can be removed by
the cooling system or
water in the case of nuclear reactors
the fuel rods can get
so hot that they can start to melt and
fall to the bottom of the reactor and
potentially melt through and escape
into the surrounding environment that's
called a nuclear meltdown
and that's also why in part the reactor
is surrounded by a containment shell of
thick steel and concrete which keeps
radioactive materials
from escaping we don't want to have any
radioactive burgers
but fuel rods don't last forever after
three to six years in a reactor fuel
rods can't sustain the fission reaction
effectively anymore and become highly
radioactive
in turn they need to be carefully
removed and stored but
what to do with nuclear waste the
problem with spent nuclear fuel is that
it's
really radioactive these leftover
radioactive materials can persist in the
air
soil and water for thousands and
thousands of years
and damage the dna of living organisms
causing cancer and other health
conditions
for a while actually quite a long time
from 1946 to 1993 to be exact
many countries just dumped radioactive
nuclear waste into the ocean
this was consequently banned and you can
imagine why
instead nuclear waste can be buried but
there's problems with that too
nuclear waste can still leak into soil
and water if it isn't properly contained
so where do we safely bury it well
nowhere really
radioactive spent fuel is stored all
over the world in various containment
systems
but none of them are truly long term
alternatively
spent fuel rods can also be recycled and
reprocessed
where unused uranium is separated from
spent nuclear fuel
however this reprocessing is quite
expensive and dangerous
reprocessing is often much more
expensive than storing or disposing of
spent nuclear fuel
and it still results in a substantial
amount of leftover
radioactive materials that still need to
be disposed of
there's no perfect solution when it
comes to energy production though
any kind of electricity production has
its own benefits and drawbacks
but pickle places atomic burger is quite
perfect
and i think i'll eat one now